dans les terrains de camping les ratons
laveurs joue les cambrioleurs un
spécialiste du comportement animal
rivalisent d'ingéniosité pour les
déjouer
ce matin une nouvelle scène de crime a
été découverte au parc national des îles
de boucherville
un voleur a ciblé deux mamans et leurs
jeunes enfants la soirée selon les
témoins avaient pourtant bien commencé
de bons moments en famille
quelques classiques gastronomique le
début de vacances tant attendues
mais tout dans la nuit un intrus s'est
glissée dans la tente le suspect serait
poilus et porterait un masque autour des
yeux
au québec les ratons laveurs sont des
habitués du gameplay les ratons d'avoir
vont être attirés par la nourriture donc
ils vont ouvrir les glacières rentrer
dans les tentes en ouvrant les
fermetures éclair ils peuvent même
ouvrir les frigos à l'intérieur des
prêts à camper ça s'est déjà vu au fil
des ans la sépaq a installé des loquets
de plus en plus complexes pour dissuader
les ratons d'entrer dans les tentes de
ses parcs nationaux
rien n'y fait les ratons laveurs sont
trop rusé
c'est reconnu que les ratons laveurs un
niveau d'intelligence très élevé même au
niveau du cerveau lui même le volume
cerveau relativement la taille d'un
animal quand même élevé pour voir un
mammifère louis l'azur et coordonnateur
de la recherche aux autres green bay
dans le cadre d'un projet doctorat qu'il
entreprit à l'université concordia il
étudie le comportement des ratons
laveurs un autre avantage que les ratons
laveurs on sait que leurs pattes nombre
pour ce qui est c'est pas comme notre
peau s'opposer à nous mais ont quand
même une certaine dextérité le haut
niveau de l'ensemble des doigts et 10
pouces qui leur permettre de manipuler
avec plus de précision certains objets
depuis deux ans il travaille avec la
sepaq pour tester l'intelligence des
ratons laveurs et leur capacité à
résoudre des problèmes
au parc national des îles de
boucherville
chercheurs a installé deux types de
castets près du site de camping réservé
aux véhicules récréatifs
les ratons laveurs doivent trouver
l'astuce pour accéder à des récompenses
caché à l'intérieur
le premier casse-tête et une simple
boîte métallique munis de roquettes ça
prend deux actions on tire le lauquet en
premier et on ouvre la porte et ensuite
le monde deuxième casse tête et deux
tubes qui glisse et tourner un sur
l'ordre et les deux tubes son trou et il
faut éliminer de troupes afin d'accéder
à un appât tôt en soirée nous avons
suivi louer d'azur alors qu'il n'a pas
testé casse tête il n'a fallu que
quelques minutes avant que deux [ __ ]
laveur se pointe pour relever le défi
le succès n'est pas toujours aussi
rapide louis l'azur place des caméras de
surveillance autour des casse-tête pour
vérifier ce qui se passe pendant la nuit
dans les trois parcs nationaux où louis
l'azur s'est installé ce de plaisance ou
de yamaska et des îles de boucherville
seulement 4% des ratons laveurs qui
tente d'ouvrir la boîte y parviennent en
moyenne ils mettent près de 7 minutes
pour obtenir la récompense
le casse tête composé de tubes s'ouvrent
plus facilement le taux de succès et de
40%
les ratons laveurs met en moyenne un peu
plus d'une minute pour l'ouvrir
en plus des casse-têtes louis l'azur
installe des pièges à proximité des
campings pour capturer des ratons
laveurs
leur est un marqueur qui permet d
identifier sur les vidéos captées durant
la nuit c'est comme ça que je vais
pouvoir évaluer l'apprentissage c'est en
voyant le même individu exposé plusieurs
fois aux mêmes problèmes et en évaluant
ainsi s'améliore ou pas une fois une
chose semble certaine les ratons laveurs
qui vivent dans les zones très
fréquentées par les humains comme les
copines qui sont plus habiles à résoudre
les casse tête que ceux qui vivent dans
les sections réservées à la conservation
ces clés [ __ ] laveur qui côtoient les
humains en plus d'occasions d'exercer
leurs méninges chaque nouvelle glace
hier où chaque mot véhicule va
représenter un défi légèrement différent
de leur capacité à résoudre le problème
est toujours ministre de l'avant
concrètement un animal qui se nourrit
d'insectes et de fruits pour qu'il soit
définitive plus répétitif et auquel les
lira-t-on l'avant était exposé depuis
des millénaires les expériences de louis
l'azur pourraient cerner les limites des
ratons laveurs et aider la sépaq
concevoir des obstacles plus efficace
mais installé des loquets plus complexe
n'est pas nécessairement la solution
ma crainte c'est qu'à un moment donné on
va atteindre un chevauchement entre les
attitudes des ratons les plus
intelligents et les capacités des gens
d'ouvrir un même cesser ces modules lol
il faut sensibiliser davantage les
campeurs pour qu'ils rangent la
nourriture et se débarrassent de leurs
déchets de façon responsable
mais ultime ans les campeurs devront
accepter de cohabiter avec les ratons
laveurs les jeunes doivent savoir qu'en
venant ici viennent dans le milieu dans
l'habitat naturel des animaux de la
forme ça se comprend les ratons l'avant
donc faut accepter cette proximité là
avec le [ __ ] laveur quand on est dans
un parc national
le vivre ensemble ça vaut aussi dans la
forêt
[Musique]